[Music]
you have no idea what you have unleashed
[Applause]
how did you get out of that plane
there's not a single scratch on your
buddy you are alive because you would
cost cursed by what the ultimate evil
welcome to a new world of gods and
monsters
you saw that right she did something to
me the very essence of evil costume now
girls
it takes a monster
defeat a monster
that's my face that's my face
[Music]
this isn't a tomb it's a prison you have
no idea what you've discovered but I
feel really separates great monster
movies from other typical horror movies
is that there's a real deep emotional
investment in the characters the
hieroglyph said she was named on-net
chosen to be Egypt's next Queen she's a
princess who's promised to become
Pharaoh but then all that was taken away
from her Dominic goes through a huge
series of transformations we've mapped
her out into five stages stage one she
is nothing but bone and rags and then
she pulls herself together literally
into this form and she begins to feed I
saw her she is real
I chose Sophia's perfectly cast as The
Mummy her soul is in her eyes and she
can't hide it and that's her gift all
she has to do is look at the camera and
you're arrested immediately I thought
there is literally no one else on the
planet who can play this part and the
way that she moves physically is
incredible I'm a net she's a warrior
this project allowed me to push my
limits
one of the great old adages is that the
villain is the hero of their own story I
think that you will connect so deeply to
her experience into what she's been
through because Sophia was amazing at
that female mummy what's your story it
grabs my attention I want to see that
movie you can't escape
she's got plans for you y'all were
states than their mr. Martin you have no
idea what you have unleashed
she's unlike anything we've ever faced
welcome to potential
[Music]
[Applause]
my character Nick he's just caught up in
this whole world that he doesn't want to
get caught up in who are you I'm a
doctor
Milan is Jekyll dr. Henry Jekyll
the central character behind all the
events of the movie is dr. Henry Jekyll
famous for being Jekyll and Hyde dr.
Jekyll approach a thing called idiom and
predict him essentially is an
organization that in points evil and
tries to neutralize him leave working
eyes examine contain destroy evil they
studied the mythology's and monsters the
histories of them princess AMA net she
selected you as the vessel for the
ultimate evil it's a science for them
and what I liked about that idea was if
we're gonna ground the monsters in a
reality
then let's ground it in science
we like the idea the prediction was
hiding in plain sight in the Natural
History Museum and that Jekyll could use
the resources of the museum to further
his own research into monsters there's a
lot to find out with Jacqueline it's not
giving too much away to say that he has
quite a clear understanding of evil it
takes a monster to defeat a monster
I love the element of mystery it's quite
dangerous and exciting
there's learn to be wary if an airline
[Music]
welcome to a new world of gods and
monsters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what-whatever than that cuz i'm safely
hidden for 2,000 years
this isn't a - its prison Nick
the hieroglyph said she was named Arnett
chosen to be Egypt's next queen but her
thirst for power led her down a darker
path one that had to be stopped because
of your actions
this ancient power has returned
[Music]
you are alive because you were chosen
sure but what evil
the ultimate evil
legend has it she's a being of
unimaginable powers now she's using him
to regain them
she will not stop until she has remade
our world
[Music]
into her own
[Music]
stay with me is good figure this out
you can't run you can't escape
she's got plans for you
mummy's gonna have great action and real
thrills we wanted to be wild and violent
and erratic and spontaneous to have Tom
Cruise in this movie is so huge for us
it just changes the game completely his
energy is infectious he's gotta top
himself every time actualize his passion
his drive his determination lights the
way for us all he fills you up with this
childhood enthusiasm where you're like I
want to make the movie the Tom scenes
[Music]
[Applause]
Tom he's ready good at pushing to keep
it real
matches every club just slam my head
against the wall tones in the vehicle
and yeah that brings on the nose he's a
good driver and he's a fast driver I
really did think okay let's just put
dumpling in there and then Tom's like
yeah sure I'll go in it I just found out
I'll be running on a building that
collapses I say to Tom let's pull the
plug on this one my dude let's bail out
and there's gonna be that adrenaline
rush and you're gonna love it and then
you're gonna go all right let's go again
let's go again
he loved it we're going zero gravity
inside a real plane Tom always pushes
the boundaries and this is one of those
yes right Tom brings out the best of
everybody he's in a scene with and he
brings every ounce of energy he has to
his performance I felt very brave around
him
he inspired a bravery and that's an
incredible gift to give someone I've
never seen somebody deaf committed in my
life
genuinely to have everyone feel proud
about the effort they've spent to make
something of quality that means a lot to
me in the world yet who could find the
game for me together every time it's
really made it
[Music]
I grew up watching these monster movies
I was a little kid I remember being
utterly terrified there is something
about those first horror movies Alex
wants to give them proper honor we owe
the audience a monster movie
there we go great
so one go the key for us was to tell a
story that felt real our picture takes
place in modern day what's interesting
about the way these stories are told is
you identify with these classic
characters they terrify us and yet you
feel sympathy for them
welcome to Buddhism this sets are
magnificent they're beautiful they're
haunting the world will feel enormous we
shot a huge action sequence here in the
heart of Africa
again zero gravity inside a real player
good Annabelle Wallis is great she's
everywhere does does afford it she's
doing this the cast they're so talented
you have Russell Crowe Jake Johnson
these guys that are fun to look with
Russell I have known each other over 20
years we've talked about working
together and now we're gonna do this
very cool fight
Sophia - teller brings a true humanity
to the mummy even when she's doing more
fine things the audience can expect to
be excruciatingly leak terrified tom
said this is bigger than anything I've
ever done before it's like being on a
rollercoaster ride that's what this film
is gonna deliver it's gonna keep you
riding the edge of your seat you're not
gonna want to take your eyes off the
screen
it's a hell of a lot of fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
No
welcome to a new world of gods and
monsters
she is real
please meet Princess Hama net she will
claim but she has been denied
[Music]
how did you get out of that plane
there's not a single scratch nobody you
are alive because of what you brought on
that plane
I remember being six years old and
seeing the original Boris Karloff mummy
and loving it so to have the opportunity
to create a monster movie in this day
and age it was very excited whatever
than has been safely hidden for 2,000
years we want the audience to feel what
would it be like if a monster entered
our world now do you have any idea what
you have unearthed the idea of a female
mummy I felt was inspiring and seductive
sofia boutella is perfectly cast
princess I'm Annette she is a warrior
Jesus survivor she wanted to honor what
she was about to become but then all
that was taken away from her there are
worse fates and she's selected you as
the vessel for the ultimate evil the
hell are you welcome to pretty Geum my
character dr. Jekyll controls an
organization called digit we recognized
examine contain and destroy evil
we have Russell Crowe brilliant actor
and I was excited when he said that he
wanted to be part of it that you have
released doesn't like anything we've
ever faced
Tom said this is bigger than anything
I've ever done before she will not stop
until she has remade our world into her
own it's about great action
it's about suspense stay with me lately
and it's about real scares Wow it gives
you such a sense of wonder I just feel
very proud to be part of it I'm excited
to reintroduce these classic monsters to
a modern audience I think the audience
should expect to be excruciatingly ly
terrified
[Music]